- I am convinced by the
complaining that's
in the market, convinced,
that we are well on our way,
I don't know where we are,
but we lost.
Just so you guys know,
I want this on the record,
I want to look back at this.
America lost.
We lost.
And by the way,
it's not because,
I love America
more than breathing.
It's because we're just too
far along in having our run
and you could just see it.
Those guys, stand up you guys,
I love you guys.
You always come when I book.
Let's clap it up for these guys.
(applause)
- You'll profit 'til the day
when you own them.
- [Gary] Well, listen, you
better fuckin' take care
of your health 'cause I need
some more time and you're old.
So get your shit
together Sugar Ray.
(laughter)
If you think those guys
from that generation
want to hear your
bullshit whining that you
don't have time,
go fuck yourself.
(laughter)
But honestly, I'm really
serious about this
please, please go talk,
if you're lucky enough,
I'm not.
I didn't really grow up with
grandparents except for one
and now she's
sick and it's tough,
go talk to your grandparents.
And go ask them to
introduce you to
four or five of their friends.
And go ask them
how they rolled in life.
Like what was tough
when there was war
and fucking Depressions
and real shit and
you're crying that
you don't have a
1,000 fucking
Periscope followers?
Get the fuck out of here.
(hip hop music)